averagely good statisticians
particularly if they're confident are
actively damaging and dangerous if you
fundamentally get it wrong this is a
case where you you can be not just a bit
wrong you can be unbelievably orders of
magnitude wrong about the assumptions
you make hey friends and welcome back to
Deep dive for the weekly podcast where
every week it's my immense privilege to
sit down with academics and authors and
creators and entrepreneurs and other
inspiring people and we find out how
they got to where they are and the
strategies and tools we can learn from
them to help us build a life that we
love Rory is the vice chairman of Ogilvy
UK which is one of the biggest marketing
and advertising companies in the world
he's the author of the book Alchemy the
surprising power of ideas that don't
make sense and he's got some absolutely
sick TED Talks that have been viewed
over 7 million times there will be so
much suspicion that we've got chat GPT
to write our thank you letters the only
way to overcome this is to actually fill
our thank you letters with profanities
so thanks very much for the [__]
dinner party it was totally boss Viva
ill Duce all our personal correspondence
will have to become kind of you know
absolutely profane in order for it to
seem sincere we talk about the
psychological value of products and how
to create value from thin air and the
power of surprising ideas in the world
of marketing and advertising if you can
imagine a stand-up comedian doing a
routine about your product then you're
on to something the urge to appear
serious is in many ways I think a
disaster in marketing and Rory says an
incredibly interesting and inspirational
person with so much life experience and
so many stories so I hope you enjoyed
this conversation as much as I did at
the moment according to the YouTube
analytics 81 of you who are watching
this on YouTube have not yet hit the
Subscribe button and so if you're for
example in the now 81 of people who are
watching this on YouTube but who are not
subscribed to the channel I would love
it if you could do so and would be
awesome to get that number down to 50
and it would be cool to get like 50 50
sub non-sub ratio just just for fun Rory
so you studied Classics at Christ
College if your Wikipedia page is to be
believed
um I was just down the road at Emmanuel
and I wonder why Classics and what did
you learn doing Classics because it
seems seems a bit Rogue to go from
classics to advertising uh well it was a
bit more Rogue than that because I made
the short-term mistake and
long-term success I think by choosing as
a levels
um maths further maths Latin and Greek
and it was a total mistake at the time
because the people doing physics
chemistry maths were effectively
um you know doing
interconnectedly the same thing whereas
I had to have this slightly skit-side
thing where you had to go from sort of
translating Homer to doing uh you know
some Advanced statistical modeling or
something and it was difficult and at
the time I think it was a mistake
um in the longer term I think it was a
great decision because one of the things
is you only have to have fairly good
statistical understanding
um for it to be a superpower in the
workplace so I said bizarrely my
brother's an astrophysicist I'm still
very interested in science particularly
uh you know the the both the potential
and the ills of quantification
um big book recommendation to start with
algorithms to live by and the alignment
problem both by Brian Christian I really
highly recommend so I read a lot of
songs I read an awful lot of
evolutionary biology as well
um because it's a new way to think
um so but the classic side was to be
honest what Classics is okay is its
modern languages for nerds okay so
there's quite a high correlation between
people who are fascinated about class
Classics and people who are fascinated
by say sci-fi because it is if you like
an alternate civilization
um and also the fact that you don't
actually have to speak to it because
everybody involved is dead probably
appeals to people who are slightly on
the Spectrum so if you're one of those
people who are undecided between science
and the Arts
um Classics is actually bizarrely a kind
of weird kind of compromise what were
you doing in a manual I studied medicine
yeah so kind of six years of medicine
two years of working and then switched
into this kind of YouTuber podcaster of
career what's interesting is that they
limit the number of people who can study
medicine in the UK
well I think that's the BMA which
pretends to be a scientific organization
but is really a trade Union for doctors
if I'm oh yeah I mean they're going to
be striking in the next few weeks
exactly now interestingly there seems to
be a premise then I I accept the value
it's very expensive getting a medical
qualification because you actually need
corpses and stuff which you don't need
for classics by and large
um
but there seems to be an axiomatic
assumption there that you only need to
train in medicine that number of people
you need to be doctors now it strikes me
that that's a fundamental fundamentally
wrong-headed idea that actually having a
surplus people with medical
qualifications would actually be despite
the cost of training would actually be
valuable it might be valuable to the
pharmaceutical industry it might be
valuable to overseas for example but
actually having a surplus of trained
doctors would actually be valuable in
all kinds of unanticipated knock-on ways
just as actually you know you don't have
to and obviously I didn't become a
Classics teacher I nearly did but I
didn't in the end
um what happened I actually trained as a
teacher after I've finished and then I
had a kind of panic attack because I
realized if I went straight into
teaching my entire life would be school
university school and I thought spending
your entire life in educational
establishments was just a bit too
limiting
and then I started applying to ad
agencies and where is this conversation
in the staff room was kind of nogius
minor has been smoking behind the bike
sheds the conversation in the Ad Agency
was I think I was waiting for my
interview at ogilvue and someone came in
and said no it wasn't that great because
I had to change planes in Addis Ababa or
something I remember thinking this you
don't get that at the staff room The
Sounds have been interesting and you
know it was the late 80s and we were all
materialistic as hell and advertising
did have that kind of Venn diagram
overlap between pretty interesting
reasonably lucrative okay
um but but but I mean it is interesting
how there is a kind of shallow logic
which often pervades decisions you know
the assumption that you only train as
doctors that number of people you need
as doctors uh strikes me as a
fundamental mistake There's an
opportunity cost there that we're
probably not noticing yeah and I think
in the medicine path there's also so
there's also like weird weird
bottlenecks in the system so for example
last year there were more people
graduating medical school in the UK than
there were Foundation year Junior doctor
jobs available right but then as you go
further down the path there are a lot of
Specialties that are or most Specialties
are also over subscribed in that
applying for specialty training is
competitive further down the line and
yet there are still loads and loads of
rotor caps in every single medic and
every hospital would say oh like a third
of our rotor a quarter of our wrote has
not filled so there's some kind of
Supply demand mismatch for certain for
certain roles that is not being
fulfilled while at the same time the
positions and Specialty training are
still oversubscribed
also having people with the confidence
to speak about medicine you know you
could have a managerial role in the NHS
where someone who is medically qualified
patently has some sort of credibility
that uh you know an average you know a
box ticker wouldn't have and there's all
you know there's all kind of value the
idea I think I think we have a very huge
sort of weird utilitarian view of
Education which is that everything has
to be directly
to serve some particular need I
completely disagree with this I mean in
in a sense doing maths and Classics were
fantastic training for going into direct
marketing because you could write I mean
one thing about Classics is it teaches
you to write basically because German
would be the same the understanding of
grammar means you can look at a sentence
and confidently say that's okay
quote of Sir John Plum I think nothing
blocks the creative mind more than fear
of a solarism or something but but the
um the fact that you can confidently
write a sentence and go that's okay
combine that with to be honest okay my
if I'm in charge of maths education and
Rishi seems to be promoting it into the
sixth form which I don't think is a bad
idea a lot of people in the creative
Industries are going there you know but
actually provided it's a different kind
of maths in particular
um statistical understanding because
even highly educated journalists are
obviously total idiots when it comes to
the interpretation of Statistics what do
you mean Kathy Newman
um I mean you know okay her argument
with Jordan Peterson which is you know
in other words you know uni various
analysis of gender of gender
differentials with no one in the social
sciences would dream of doing okay I
mean you know a lot of journalists are
obviously statistically completely
illiterate if you look at something like
The Meadows case
um okay it was um
uh it was it was a case where a fairly
eminent medic uh posited that the chance
of two cop deaths in a single household
could be determined by multiplying the
odds together as though there were no
external factors either genetic or
Environmental
failing to actually
um accept the fact that both deaths were
male which also increases the
probability of God death but also
failing to do the elementary thing of
comparing the probability of a
double-cot death with the probability of
a double infanticide which is what you
actually have to do which changes the
odds from something like overwhelmingly
guilty
um with a wrong statistical model to
most likely innocent literally only more
than 50 chance of Innocence once you
compare the two probabilities not
effectively essentially saying uh well
if it you know if it isn't accident it's
murder it's completely imbalanced but
but but people with literally people
with Oxbridge degrees who are eminent in
the medical fraternity made that mistake
Barrister's judges made that mistake so
if if this extra maths is largely around
statistics I mean I've never needed in
my entire life to to work out the
surface area of a cone and if I needed
to do that I think it is a third
be a third height times pi r squared of
the radius of the base I'm guessing this
is about right it's something like that
okay I've never needed to do that and if
I did I'd Google it or I'd ring up
somebody who knew okay on the other hand
basic appreciation of statistics
um I use pretty much every day to a
point where it's a kind of superpower
and so just having done what you might
call you know statistics to a level
standard and having a basic grasp of yes
but actually
um is unbelievably valuable in business
or in virtually any other context how so
like what do you mean that statistics of
the superpower
um well well it stops you being stupid
um is one of the things
um it also makes you understand a really
important Concepts like the TR you know
the trade-off between well the explore
exploit trade-off it's a really
interesting concept which appears in AI
but it also appears in things like the
studies of animal foraging okay so
there's a trade-off effectively if
you're a foraging animal or for that
matter you're an algorithm
um there's a trade-off between
exploration and exploitation which is
um you know obviously you're a total
idiot if you don't exploit what you
already know okay if you make no use of
pre-existing
um knowledge but you're equally foolish
all be it in the slightly longer term if
you don't keep exploring but simply
exploit what you know on the assumption
that it will never change and your
knowledge is utterly complete and
incapable of uh Improvement or
enhancement or or an adaptation
and so understanding a few basic
mathematical Concepts I think
um you know I'd make algorithms to live
by uh you know one of the set texts for
sixth form maths
um is really really useful I don't buy
the um
actually the other thing I don't buy is
I don't buy the a few creative people in
advertisers got really annoyed at more
people being forced to do maths because
they say I would have left school
earlier I can't stand maths depends on
the maths because I mean it's worth
noting that
um you know solving mathematical
Problems by effectively rewriting the
question
or you know redefining the problem yep
okay which is what an awful lot of
advanced maths is is actually a highly
creative act and you could actually make
maths teaching actually almost a form of
um creative teaching yes if you got it
right
you mentioned that you wouldn't be
surprised if marketing was uh became
mostly female in the future why why is
that um
are you just plotting the direction of
travel okay
um partially that
um
uh generally
as of now I'm not suggesting it's innate
uh women seem to manifest uh a
preference for working in people
businesses slightly more not suggesting
it's innate it could be culturally
inculcated but doesn't really matter
because that seems to be happening that
point you know I don't know there we go
Jordan Peterson but the weird thing that
when you actually make employment uh you
know more and more a matter of choice
weirdly uh in some cases gender
differences actually increase rather
than reducing
um
uh also also I mean for example I think
that there'll be a very very substantial
um uh Indian uh contingent in marketing
and advertising uh because in India it's
it's very high status you have these
extraordinary kind of universities
extraordinary high level of Education
around marketing
um not only in universities but places
like Unilever Hindustan lever which are
kind of almost universities and
themselves and you can simply see the
extraordinary Talent the extraordinary
marketing Talent
um that's been produced I mean what we
have the head of Ford North America
Indian MasterCard both I think the CEO
and the marketing director you know you
go you go on and on and on and
um uh you know it's absolutely clear-cut
that um there's okay okay let's not
let's not neglect the base rate okay 1.5
billion people like game which kind of
helps yeah uh but but I you know I I
just find it interesting because I think
what often happens if you're bad at
statistics you're not wrong to be angry
about these things but either you get
angry about the wrong thing or you have
the wrong idea about how to solve the
problem
some degree of disparity will emerge
from preference yeah because preference
emerges from circumstance okay and
therefore if different groups actually
grow up in different circumstances uh
you would expect their preferences to
differ and so if you don't account for
that and you suggest that every single
disparity is the role of either active
or unconscious prejudice I'm not saying
you're wrong to discuss Prejudice I'm
merely saying that you're miscalibrating
it
and that there are other factors going
on that we need to take into account
yeah and it worries me a bit because you
know you know a lot of this is kind of
HR dominated and um
uh you know
HR isn't necessarily the
um epicenter of sophisticated
statistical understanding if we're to be
blunt about it and so you know we've got
to be I mean as with um with Sally Clark
case you know uh the the cop death case
oh yeah um getting statistics wrong is
really goddamn dangerous
um and actually I mean I was watching
I'll just give you an interesting point
here which is that it's worth noting
that if the data you collect is
unrepresentative then the conclusions
you will draw will be similarly biased
okay
and first of all which is a kind of
quote of mine which gets adopted by
other people all big data comes from the
same place the past okay and it's only
reliable
um even if it's representative of what
you truly need to know which is a big if
it's only reliable if you can actually
confidently say that the future is going
to be very similar to the Past
okay which in the short term maybe a
safe assumption over a decade not so
much okay
um I was talking to someone last night
who had worked for
um a big Dairy company which delivered
milk
and um they had things down to an
absolute Fine Art until suddenly the law
changed and it was you were now allowed
to buy milk from a supermarket I mean I
think I can dimly remember when that
happened but it might have been it might
have been earlier actually it might have
been the early 60s before I was born now
you know at that point everything you
think you know
you know is no longer reliable as an
assumption
and um the point I'm making there is
that
um if you um if you don't actually
understand the limitations of your data
or the biases of your data yeah and
obviously quantification bias uh it's
much easier to get data on things which
happen to be you know numerical or
measurable in terms of Si derived units
yep okay but if I mean if if you
fundamentally get it wrong this is a
case where you you can be not just a bit
wrong you can be unbelievably orders of
magnitude wrong about the assumptions
you make and one of the things that
worries me okay is let's assume that the
quality of people's statistical
understanding is on a bell curve okay
um then you know with you know a little
tale of a very very good statisticians
and then then there are people who just
know nothing on the left-hand side
they're not too worried about them
people who don't know anything don't
possibly let's hope won't pretend to do
anything but what that does mean is that
averagely good statisticians are going
to massively out number really good
statisticians okay well that's true in
lots of fields I'm sure the averagely
good plumbers okay uh massively
outnumbered really really good plumbers
but averagely good plumbers are still
useful they still do a good bit of
Plumbing from time to time and assuming
the job isn't like you know the cooling
system for a nuclear power station
they're probably good enough okay
whereas okay averagely good
statisticians particularly if they're
confident are actively damaging and
dangerous hmm
yeah and so you know there's something
we got it's something we've got to be
really really alert to because it's like
if you if you overlay the bell curve
onto the dining sugar curve you'll end
up with a very large proportion of very
confident but very uh ill-informed
people about statistics yeah and almost
anything else
yeah and particularly if they're
confident or if they're simply overly
preoccupied with the neatness of the
model yep not with how the model
actually differs reality
um because you occasionally get this
kind of pure now actually let's be fair
a lot of very good statisticians
absolutely ring what they say with
qualifications but then unfortunately
they're reporting to people who don't
have the same nuanced understanding
all right we're just going to take a
quick break from the podcast to
introduce our sponsor which is huel now
this is very exciting because I've
actually been a pain customer of huel
since 2017. I started eating Hill in my
fifth year of medical school and I've
been using heal regularly ever since
because you know I like to be productive
I you know my calendar is full with a
lot of things and often I don't have the
time or don't make the time to have a
particularly healthy breakfast or a
particularly healthy lunch and heal is
fantastic for those occasions because
it's 400 calories they've got tons and
tons of different flavors my favorite
flavor is salted caramel because for
that you get 400 calories you also get
40 grams of protein super hard to get
enough protein in my diet these days
especially with trying to get hinge and
working out he'll just make sure that I
get at least those 40 grams in the 400
calories and it's got 26 different
vitamins and minerals which really helps
with the whole healthy balanced diet
thing as well now I don't use heal with
every meal I wouldn't recommend using it
with every meal but in those occasions
where you find yourself reaching for a
very unhealthy snack we're about to
order a really unhealthy takeaway it's
just absolutely fantastic being able to
have the option now I use the heel black
edition in the mornings it's very nice I
put two scoops of powder into my little
blender type I add water sometimes a bit
of milk and that gives me what I need
but also for lunch I like using the huel
hot and savory product they've got which
basically you add boiling water to this
container of stuff and you can make
yourself like a they've got a really
good cheese pasta type one which is
which is my favorite thing and again
also all of these are nutritionally
complete meals they're all vegan they
all have all these nutrients and
vitamins and minerals and stuff and
they're often reasonably high protein as
well and it's also ridiculously cost
effective like one of these meals is one
pound 68 for a 400 calorie meal which is
like a tenth of the price of what I
would be ordering from deliveroo instead
and so really huel is a perfect
companion for a busy life where you want
to get a lot of things done and you
don't if you don't necessarily have a
lot of time to cook a healthy meal and
deal with all the prep and all the
shopping and all the cleanup then heal
is a great addition to your life rather
than a replacement for all of the meals
in your life anyway if that sounds
appeal Street and you want to try out
heal then if you head over to heel.com
forward slash deep dive that URL is a
special URL which will give you a free
t-shirt and a free Shaker thing with
your first order and so yeah head over
to heel.com forward slash deep dive and
thank you so much Hill for sponsoring
this episode this episode is very kindly
brought to you by trading 212. now
people ask me all the time for advice
about investing because I've made a
bunch of videos about it on the YouTube
channel and my advice for most people is
generally invest in Broad stock market
index funds which is exactly what you
can do completely for free with trading
212. it's a great app that lets you
trade stocks and funds and ETFs and
foreign exchange if you really want to
and one of the great things about the
app is that if you're new to the world
of investing you can actually invest
with fake money you don't have to put
real money in they've got a practice
mode where you invest fake money and
then it actually tracks what the market
is doing in real time so you can see had
I invested 100 pounds into this thing
what would my return have been X weeks
or X months further down the line once
you've got some comfort with that then
it's super easy to deposit money into
your trading tube into account you can
use Apple pay like I do initially or you
can use a direct bank transfer and then
once the money is in your trading 212
account then you can invest it in
basically whatever you want now if
you're based in the UK you might be
familiar with the concept of an Isa
which is an individual savings account
which is basically a tax-free wrapper
that you can put money in you can put 20
000 pounds in every year up to twenty
thousand pounds and it resets every
April and then all that money can grow
and it's completely tax-free for the
rest of your life and if you want to
sign up for an iso you can sign up for
one completely for free also on trading
212. so if you haven't yet filled up
your eyes allowance or at least put some
money into your Isa for this year that
might be a good step forward the app
also lets you Auto invest which is a
great thing because then you can
automatically invest a percentage of
your paycheck into the thing every month
and so if you haven't yet started with
investing and you want to give it a go
then you can download the app on the App
Store and if you use the coupon code Ali
Ali at the checkout that will give you a
totally free share worth up to 100
pounds it's available on iPhone and
Android and you can check it out by
typing in trading 212 into your
respective App Store so thank you so
much trading 212 for sponsoring this
episode in one of your I think was one
of your TED Talks or a talk that you
gave you said uh something interesting
you said that
um a lot of
in marketing and I guess in in life in
general there's
um a lot of stuff that gets missed
because people are afraid to ask what
seems like a stupid question and so at
the risk of asking what potentially is a
stupid question
um what is marketing
Cummings was regarded as being a bit of
an ass okay by people on civil service
for continually asking why hmm
and it was regarded as childish it's
absolutely not childish it's actually a
very very intelligent approach because
generally what happens is that
intermediate objectives start dominating
the
um a dominating what you might call
attention
at the expense of what is the ultimate
objective okay
and so act that business of going why
five times in a row which apparently
within Downing Street the sort of senior
civil servants regarded as you know
practically as if you were banging
knives and forks on the table going me
wanting tins okay
um it's not it's it looks childish it's
not necessarily a high status Behavior
but this is one of the most interesting
things I think I think in complex
systems
um okay uh in in understanding of
complex systems in understanding of
Newtonian systems there's a kind of
hierarchy of importance there's the big
stuff which has big effects and there's
the small stuff that has small effects
okay
and therefore you know if you pretend
that the economy or that your business
is a sort of Newtonian reductionist
model which I think management itself do
because they come from engineering and
when they want to model anything they
tend to model it as a machine okay now
in a machine for example everything
tends to have one function
and therefore you can Define what
something is for this is what I call the
dormant fallacy I don't know if you come
across okay
so the Dorman fallacy is you get a bunch
of Consultants into your five-star hotel
and they go they Define the Dorman's
function as opening the door which is
notionally what a dormant was for uh in
the days before automatic doors of
course it's a you know it's it's really
just a you know linguistic convenience
Dorman do many many other things quite a
lot of them tacit you know recognition
security gossiping with other Dorman you
know
um actually just maintaining the status
of the hotel because if you want to
charge 400 quid a night you kind of got
to have a dormant them as the rules
right and what the consulting firm do is
they go in they Define the Dorman's role
as
um opening the door
and then they say well look with our
Tech Partners who are probably paying us
some sort of commission will replace
your doorman with an automatic opening
sliding door with an infrared you know
human recognition mechanism and you know
over the next five years that's going to
save you X and everybody in the
procurement and Logistics function all
clap and go marvelous we've secured this
saving and off the Consultants go okay
and then five years later you discover
the rack rates now fallen by 50 and
their vagrants asleep in the hotel
entrance because the doorman was doing
lots of other things which weren't
captured by your mod your mechanistic
model of the world yep okay
and I see that happening a lot when Tech
replaces
um
generally I'm pretty happy when Tech
augments the options of a consumer you
know when when pay by smartphone app at
car Parks came along I was ecstatically
grateful because car parking was now
typically costing six quid and having
six pound coins or whatever was you know
bloody painful okay so you know okay as
option as an alternative that's great
yeah then what you notice is unless
you've got a smartphone you can't park
which effectively means that my dad
who's 92 can't use a car park if we're
not careful okay and so one of the
things I think we've got to be really
careful of is that fur line trap where
something comes along as an option
you know live chat you know on the
screen help whatever it may be come as
long as an option we're all unbelievably
grateful for it and love it because it's
an option and then it's a bit like New
Coke Classic Coke you know the the I
think this is probably
um uh this is probably
um anecdotal but one of the research
mistakes they made with new Coke was
they didn't explain to people that this
would replace old Coke so people go oh
do I like this yeah okay I'm all in
favor of having a new variant of Coke
it was only when they realized that old
coat classic Coke was being withdrawn
that they suddenly went no no I don't
like this at all okay now what you know
what you see I've done there is okay is
I think that in complex systems it's
kind of fractal there are recurring
patterns and the patterns recur at a
small scale and a big scale so you can
take something from the sale of
chocolate bars okay and you can apply it
to a tax system
okay you can take an Insight from
um well actually okay you can take an
Insight from a supermarket loyalty
program yep okay
and you can uh you can give advice to
the treasury on how they should design
taxation how okay very simple let's take
the boots Advantage card you get
marvelous thing by the way I helped
learn [__]
um yeah my mom is a big fan no no
fantastic thing well there's some
fascinating things about them but it's
Advantage gun one of which is in
defiance of um logic or economic logic
rather what quite often happens is wife
gets ill typically more more female than
males have an advantage card just
because I'm not being sexist okay wife
gets ill okay says the husband needs
some nurofen and some whatnot okay can
you go to Boots and buy me these various
medical provisions
um just as he's leaving okay she's oh by
the way take my advantage card so you'll
get the points he goes along picks up
the neurofan and you know whatever else
goes to the channel hands over the
advantage card at which point the the
person that tells us actually you can
buy these all on the punks you've got on
the card and he goes brilliant okay it
goes back to wife says
um I uh I didn't actually pay for any of
this I got it all with your points
and she's Furious right now you're gonna
go what okay what the hell is going on
there because it's immaterial in
economic terms whether you spend the
points on European or whether you spend
it on a Chanel number 19. however we
prefer buying indulgences on points
than with money because it's less
guilt-inducing okay
it's rather like you know it's a lot
less painful going business class using
your avios points than it is using your
money okay
um and even though the advantage points
actually have a cash value okay
nonetheless there's a very clear
demarcation in the mind cookie jar
accounting Richard Taylor calls it
between what you you know we actually
apportion different forms of money
towards different ends and therefore if
you use what's the treat budget for the
Staples purchases it violates some basic
sense of of internal mental accounting
okay now the other one that's
interesting is that let's imagine that
instead of launching the advantage card
boots had simply dropped all their
prices by four percent rather than
giving four percent back in the shape of
points okay
um
uh three years three years later
everybody would have forgotten about it
nobody would have noticed much of the
time actually okay except the really
only retentive kind of you know value
Chasers okay and everybody would have
forgotten about it six months later yeah
the points retain their salience
God what is it getting on for I don't
know roughly 15 20 years after that card
was launched
now here okay so here's my suggestion
right we should never ever cut taxes we
should pay people a rebate when it's
possible
but there's a reduction in the tax rate
basically loses meaning it has a
half-life of about 12 months in terms of
its meaning and significance
an annual tax rebate a a lump sum will
be appreciated far more than just a
reduction in your your outgoings okay
secondly it will retain its salience in
perpetuity thirdly because it's mentally
framed as a bonus not a price cut okay
under exceptional circumstances EG
someone invades a neighboring country
okay there's a massive hike in the price
of fuel there's a problem with the tax
take for a short term you can withdraw
the rebate much more painfully much more
painlessly than you can actually
increase taxes okay you can say for this
year only
okay
whereas we tend to feel I think if tax
rates go up that it's a ratchet it's
going to be a long long time before they
go back down again so this business
where you can literally take
psychological insights through a loyalty
program and deploy them in a completely
different domain and now what militates
against it is this status idea in
conversation okay
where important people talk about big
things like interest rates you know and
the FED okay and you delegate small
things down to Junior people now I have
this I have this Mantra which is dare to
be trivial because I argue that in
complex systems the interesting pattern
is just as likely to reveal itself at
the level of chocolate bars and loyalty
programs
okay
um I'll give you another beautiful
example of this okay now those of you
who are older listening will remember a
thing called BT friends and family
and that's where you nominated 10 of the
people you called the most and you got
15 off those calls now stand-up
comedians talked about friends and
family people in the pub talked about
which 10 numbers and it was a bit
embarrassing because actually one of
their friends and family was you know I
don't know a sex line okay but that that
achieved a level of mental saliency now
it was 15 off 10 numbers now admittedly
if you chose your top 10 moves all the
Pareto effect that was probably like a
10 discount
people were engaged with friends and
family over 10 years if BT had simply
dropped their core prices across the
board by 15 everybody would have
forgotten about it almost immediately
now here's where I say dare to be
trivial right
if you want to understand patterns that
are telling
there is no telling because it's kind of
fractal there's no telling at what scale
the pattern is going to be most Salient
or most visible yep okay and it is
absolutely foolish
to view the study of Supermarket loyalty
programs or chocolate bar promotions as
being lower status than talking about
Janet Yellen and the [__] fed okay
and let me explain why a very simple
Point okay if you'd gotten to the
Galapagos Islands in the early 19th
century you would have seen a bearded
guy in an enormous hat wandering around
measuring the beaks of finches okay and
almost anybody would have looked at this
and thought what's that okay however it
was in those telling details you know I
mean you can't get much more anal than
you know Finch beak comparison right I
mean I would regard discussing loyalty
programs as you know comparatively
high-minded compared to that okay and
yet that's that's where the ship reveals
itself yep and so I think this business
of status where status is appropriate
where big things have big effects and
small things in in the real world
because the human brain creative people
okay creative people are annoying to
Ordinary People I I suddenly realized my
daughter has um one of my daughters has
sort of ADHD
and it's mostly hereditary and I
suddenly realized when I looked at the
diagnosis of it that I'd had it myself
and one of the things it creates is a
kind of incomprehension with people who
don't have it because you don't have a
sense of proportion in some some
respects and then in occurred to me in
complex systems in dealing with complex
systems problems or creative problems
where they're a potential Butterfly
Effects you're right not to have a sense
of proportion because the solution is
just as likely to lie in something
seemingly trivial or tangential as it is
in something notionally important
okay so actually the sense of proportion
of the status around what you might call
the higher twaddle which is its high
status to talk about interest rates and
then what you end up with then is your
insistence on only talking about what
you might call high-end things like the
inflation rate the interest rate blah
blah blah blah okay
what that does is it massively limits
your creative solution space because
you're left with a tiny little Overton
window of a few seemingly big things
that you're allowed to tweak
and actually loads and loads of really
interesting solutions that lie elsewhere
are totally unexplored
because they're beneath your dignity
yeah
okay where's the where's the balance
here because traditional business advice
is let's say you're the CEO of the
company you focus on the big picture
stuff the mission the vision the values
the stuff where it will by changing the
course one percent that multiplied out
over the 100 people you've got in your
company means that the company will
change direction
um but then you get stories of people
like Steve Jobs getting involved with
like line height and letter spacing and
font choice and all that stuff which is
completely counter to what a CEO of a
company should be doing oh
okay I did go and see a talk by Johnny
Ive once and I must say there was more
discussion of bezels than I thought was
all together help me okay
but
um
well let me let let me tell a story okay
which is that in I think practically you
know two weeks before the launch of the
iPhone Steve Jobs had a you know an
early prototype in his pocket with a
plastic screen
and uh he kept his keys on the same
pocket which frankly is stupid about you
know you know get a grip Steve you know
T is in the left pocket phone of the
right it's not difficult but anyway for
whatever reason the Steve kept his keys
in the same book in his phone and the
screen was scratched
and
more or less with you know weeks to go
he just went okay can the screen we're
going for Gorilla Glass okay
then I think it was actually a bit
unpleasant because the first delivery of
Gorilla Glass turned up with Foxconn at
two o'clock in the morning and all the
workers were basically turfed out of
their beds to start assembling iPhones
okay
um but nonetheless okay very very few
people would have done that would have
had that perfectionistic urge and
actually you know art Artistry
craftsmanship is to some extent about a
lot of proportion in other words you
know God is in the details as I think
it's me's vanderer isn't it you know the
fact that I mean service to some extent
okay any service business to some extent
achieves its distinctiveness in Trivial
details um every bit as much as it does
in uh you know setting service level
agreements which are because let's face
it if if if you're if your table Stakes
are the same as everybody else's table
Stakes no one's really going to comment
or notice whereas you have that
extraordinary place the um I think it's
all the Magic Castle in Los Angeles days
which is a pretty unprepossessing hotel
which always seems to be in the top 10
hotels in on TripAdvisor and one of the
reasons is not the only reason I'm sure
the staff are pretty great as well they
have this Popsicle hotline which is
your kids are by the pool they pick up
this red phone and go popsicles please
and someone comes out their ice lollies
to a British audience and someone
basically comes out with a tray of ice
lollies for free that costs them almost
nothing but actually directing service
gestures towards people's kids is a
particularly clever thing to do actually
uh you know a good bit of evolutionary
psychology here but making a fuss of
people's kids actually gratifies the
parents more than if you make a fuss of
them great bit of advice from
um great man called Mr srider who ran
Ogilvy in India was always you know when
you buy a present buy it for the
client's children
um yeah good darwinian stuff
um and um uh but you know I I just
didn't know hotel in Portugal once which
was a pretty good hotel but then when
because we had young children uh every
day we came back to our room the um uh
the people doing the room had turned the
towels into an elephant or a swan or
something like this which my children at
the time you know were absolutely there
are six twenty okay they're absolutely
ecstatic about it okay that sort of
stuff is in many ways it's it's very
different you can't formularize it
because the very fact that you're doing
something personalized and discretionary
is what gives it all the meaning you
know the degree of personalization and
the degree of discretion
no one would ever say I thought that was
an extremely unsatisfactory Hotel
because they failed to fill my towels
into strange animals okay that's exactly
the point that's why it seems amazing
because politeness good manners are to
some extent discretionary efforts you
know holding a door for someone writing
a thank you letter
Etc I do have an interesting debate
about that and this week's spectator
which is that
um there will be so much suspicion that
we've got chat GPT to write our thank
you letters that the only way to
overcome this is to actually fill our
thank you letters with profanities so
thanks very much for the [__] dinner
party okay uh it was totally boss you
know Viva IL Duce because of course chat
GPT can't say anything right wing and it
can't say nothing rude okay and it can't
say anything opinionated so what we'll
have to do is all our personal
correspondence will have to become kind
of you know absolutely profane in order
for it to seem sincere
this episode is very kindly brought to
you by wework now this is particularly
exciting for me because I have been a
full paying customer of wework for the
last two years now I discovered it
during you know when the pandemic was in
the on the verge of being lifted and I
spent like the whole year just sort of
sitting in my room making YouTube videos
but then I discovered wework and I was a
member me and Angus my team members we
were members of the wework in Cambridge
and they have like hundreds of other
locations worldwide as well and it was
incredible because we had this fantastic
beautifully designed office space to go
to to work and we found ourselves like
every day just at nine o'clock in the
morning just going to wework because it
was a way nicer experience working from
the co-working space than it was just
sitting at home working these days what
me and everyone in my team has is the
all access pass which means you're not
tied to a specific wework location but
it means you can use any of their
several hundred co-working spaces around
London around the UK and also around the
world and one of the things I really
love about the co-working setup is that
it's fantastic as a bit of a change of
scenery so these days I work from home
I've got the studio at home but if I
need to get some focused writing work
done and I've been I'm feeling a bit
drained just sitting at my desk all day
I'll just pop over to the local wework
which is about a 10 minute walk from
where I am I'll take my laptop with me
I've got some free coffee from there
I'll get a few snacks and it's just such
a great Vibe and you get to meet cool
people I've made a few friends through
meeting them at wework and it's just
really nice being an environment almost
like a library but kind of nicer because
there's like a little bit of soft music
in the background and there's other kind
of startup Bros and creators and stuff
in in there as well and it's just my
absolute favorite co-working space of
all time it's super easy to book a desk
or book a conference room using the app
and it's a great place to meet up with
team members if you're going to
collaborate and you'll live in different
places they've got unlimited tea and
coffee and herbal teas and drinks on tap
and they've got soundproof booths in
which they take Zoom calls and meetings
anyway if you're looking for a
co-working space for you or your team
that I'd 100 recommend we work like I
said I've been a pain customer for
theirs for the last two years which is
why it's particularly exciting that
they're now sponsoring this episode and
if you want to get 50 off your first
booking then do head over to we.com
forward slash Ali and you can use the
coupon code Ali at checkout Ali to get
50 off your first booking so thank you
so much wework for sponsoring this
episode I was at this uh marketing
Mastermind conference type thing in
Miami last week uh and one of the guys
gave a really good talk about
um Word of Mouth marketing yeah uh and
one of his main points was that the
reason the way you get Word of Mouth Is
by having these kind of talk triggers
having certain things about the service
or something that are remarkable and
therefore worth remarking on
Purple Cow I think there's a book by
Seth Godin where he almost suggests I
think purple in purple cow you build
talkability into the product yeah and I
often say that if you can build
something into the product and imagine a
stand-up we've got a funny enough
there's a uh a brilliant creative
approach I can't tell you about that
ogilvy's just come up with for the mayor
of the mayor of London okay and it meets
this perfectly which is if you can
imagine a stand-up comedian doing a
routine about your product okay
um then you're on to something you know
you know in other words if it almost
requires you to you know sacrifice your
own you know some of your own
seriousness this is what I mean about
status okay the urge to appear serious
is in many ways I think a disaster in
marketing because marketing marketing
looks at the world from at a 90 degree
angle to the rest of the organization
the rest of the organization looks at it
through an efficiency lens
actually an exploit lens not an explore
lens
and everything is an optimization
problem okay we look at things through
the consumer's own eyes over time they
look at things as a snapshot aggregate
okay as a result their view of the world
is when it comes to customers very
stupid because the snapshot aggregate
doesn't tell you anything about your
customers in fact it's woefully
misleading because the average customer
probably doesn't even exist okay
and so I'll give you a perfect example
of that which I've been ranting about
repeatedly which is high speed one is a
fantastic idea but it took a long time
to get off the ground am I used to use
in the early years you probably got a
carriage to yourself oh I wonder if you
can give some context on that for the
International Grocery
okay so high speed one runs from Kent
which is a count a very big County and
gloriously beautiful
um he says there's a Kent property owner
um uh the um but it's adjacent to London
but it's it at its furthest point it's
about 60 to 70 miles from Central London
okay think of it as kind of kinetic plus
the southern bit of what is it
Massachusetts I don't know something
like that what that is they built on the
back of the Eurostar they wouldn't have
built it out otherwise but since there
was a high speed line going to Paris uh
from some pancreas to the coast in
folkestone they decided that the Euro
started didn't generate enough traffic
to justify this line on its own so they
ran uh local effectively commuter
services at very high speed so suddenly
you could get from Ashford to London in
37 minutes or 30 minutes to Stratford
would you believe it whereas previously
it had taken I think 90 if I'm right it
might have been slightly less
um it was certainly over an hour okay
now if you think about that
what that means is that someone in
Ashford who decides to work in London
effectively saves
an hour a day 200 times a year probably
a bit less with flexible working but you
get my point
okay hot now what the people who design
Railways do when they make a
justification for the investment in time
saving is they basically give an
economic opportunity cost to all time
spent on a train
okay and they calculate the value of the
time saving by the Assumption which is
ludicrous by the way that all-time
spends in transit is economically
unproductive in fact anybody who works
on a train knows it can be the best
moment of your I fantasize about three
hour train Journeys because you can
actually get your [__] done right the
whole premise is [__] stupid okay but
anyway even on that premise okay it
doesn't distinguish between one person
saving an hour 200 times a year
and 200 people saving an hour once a
year sure now High Speed 2 which runs
from London to Manchester we're not
going to get not many people can afford
to commute from Manchester to London and
so it's not the same as Canterbury
Ashford folkestone Ramsgate okay not the
same as those places where you could
conceivably work in London at least
three days a week maybe five and pay the
commuting cost okay
this is a journey which
all but of very very few people take
once a year naught times a year maybe in
my case four times a year London
Manchester London match okay now saving
a lot of people an hour infrequently
looks the same to the statistical model
as saving a few people an hour every day
well very frequently okay I would argue
that in psychological and behavioral
terms these things although
mathematically identical in the
aggregate are totally different one of
the means hey wow I can now get a job in
London or for a Londoner which wouldn't
be a bad move by the way hey wow I can
move to Canterbury right
all right or the Seaside deal you know
Walmart sorry I'm just helping out the
local estate okay okay
sandwich okay broadstairs whitstable
okay now
uh the interesting thing there is I I
think it's absolutely fallacious to
treat those things as if they're
commutative as if one times a hundred is
the same as 100 times one and what a
marketer would do is a marketer would
say well how is this going to change
Behavior looked at Through The Eyes of
20 different people
and they might look at high speed 2 and
go meh and they might look at high speed
one and go actually that's a bit of a
game changer okay it's a niche audience
but it's a hell of a game changer this
will actually change Bear In Mind by the
way when it was built just be clear
um East Kent was although you know one
of the home counties it was the only
part of the southeast England where
average property prices were less than
five times average income it was to some
extent economically uh a little deprived
and therefore uh spending this money was
non-non-intelligent thing to do at all
so what I'm saying is that as a marketer
you will always be at honest with the
rest of the organization because you're
looking at things at literally
orthogonas no or actually
perpendicularly to them they're looking
at Aggregates because they're reporting
up to the shareholders yeah okay and
they're interested in just aggregate
figures how does this all add up and
where necessary we'll take an average
what we're doing is actually taking the
consumer's eye view which is literally
at 90 degrees so this idea by the way
that data is objective is absolutely
untrue
what data tells you entirely depends on
the context and the angle at which you
look at it so quite often
um sequential
um what what's the correct term for a
cohort data or longitudinal data okay
tells a very very different story to
comparisons of snapshot data so now just
be clear about this okay I'm not saying
that in wealth inequality isn't a
problem okay but I'm saying that if you
want to solve the problem you've got to
actually Define it properly and one of
the interesting things is that actually
quite a few people will go from the
poorest quartile to the richest quartile
of the population in the course of their
lifetime most data on wealth inequality
on widening wealth inequality just
compares the top and bottom quartile at
one point to the top and bottom quartile
another Point without not acknowledging
that they're not the same people so for
example a newly qualified Barrister
probably very heavily in debt probably
qualifies as being notionally and the
poorest deaths out of the population now
nobody thinks that guy as poor because
his prospects are pretty good in fact
banks will lend the guy probably pretty
readily okay but it's it's vitally
important that we the idea that when you
have a charge or when you have data that
it will deliver objective information
regardless of how you actually
interrogate it is complete nonsense you
can take exactly the same data and if
you want to you can use it to tell two
completely different stories you know
quite a lot of people by the way I mean
you know one facet of wealth inequality
is simply that old people are richer
than poor people because they've bought
they've accumulated more [__] over time
okay yeah
now
you know now you might argue you could
actually interestingly you could have a
society where everybody was getting poor
which was getting poorer on average over
time but where everybody was getting
richer over the course of their life
okay now that actually might be a
weirdly relatively contented Society
whereas a society which was getting
richer on average but where everybody
was getting poorer over the course of
their life psychologically would be a
completely different thing they're both
possible by the way and they're both
unusual yeah but they're both theoretic
both both situations of theory I'm
struggling to imagine this in my mind
yeah so you just have in other words you
have young people who are getting much
much richer all the time and then just
going into sort of total decline okay
over life but nonetheless the aggregate
population is getting richer
there are other debates which no one can
touch
um statistically which is uh everybody
treats equal opportunity as though it's
one generation at a time okay in other
words that you in other words your
prospects should be independent of your
parents wealth means okay
and it's axiomatic that equality of
opportunity means that
yeah okay yeah however
I think we would find such a society
almost intolerable oh how so well if in
other words you could go from you know
very rich parents this must have
happened on Cambodia under Paul pot I'm
guessing Okay but if you have that thing
where you you know literally people with
you know wealthy middle class parents
were forced to work in a lathe Factory
regardless of what they wanted to do Etc
in the interest of fairness okay because
unfortunately your upbringing has some
bearing on your preferences yep you know
uh and actually this is an interesting
case because what we regard as
statistically desirable might actually
not be very pleasant in reality simply
because you could fall to you you've got
to remember that for people to rise fast
okay different in the 1960s you had
massive expansion of the middle class
right so you can have an awful lot of
people could be utterly mobile at that
time unless you actually expand the
middle I would argue the middle class is
already uselessly large
okay but unless you unless you continue
to expand the fiddle class to to the
point of absurdity
um you're not going to have that that's
not gonna that's a one-off that's not a
you know uh that's not a um an eternal
uh opportunity
and actually
uh you might argue that the price in in
how far people have to fall in terms of
loss aversion would actually outweigh
the pleasure of the people who gained
well what is marketing and like what got
you interested in it in the first place
um right well very interestingly I as I
said there was this slightly banal end
of the 80s here's a job which isn't
boring like Banking and yet it's
reasonably lucrative it's not totally
you know Polaris like um the you know
publishing or something okay so that
that Drew me in and then by very very
happy accident I didn't get a job in a
conventional Ad Agency I nearly did two
of them just missed out and ended up
getting a job at a play school then
oglevin made the direct
which was a direct marketing agency
which is selling off the page direct
mail
um telemarketing okay okay where you're
sort of that was my graduate training
job and David Ogilvy actually
um recommended that anybody who wanted
to be an advertising creative should
spend their first four years in direct
marketing learning what actually worked
so so what is direct marketing as the
thing from other forms I think most
digital marketing would probably be
defined as direct marketing by the you
know definition of the time but back
then you didn't have email I suppose you
had fax marketing telephone marketing
because
um or it was anything which effectively
sought to
uh build a relationship with the person
you're selling to so you found their
name and address at the time which meant
you could send them direct mail or you
mailed them for acquisition you use
direct mail for acquisition or you
um uh you know all you operated at call
centers there was anything where there
was a one-to-one contact Direct because
as distinct from marketing products
which are sold through intermediaries
like supermarkets okay okay so
if Dove writes to a consumer that's
direct marketing okay if Dove places an
ad on TV and you walk into Tesco's and
buy some doubts yeah that's not okay
got it so a Facebook ad would be oh well
yeah it probably is because you know who
it is who's yeah yeah we never realized
we were going to create that monster uh
in a way and it's gone from being
um direct marketing has probably gone
from being underused to overused okay a
typical neophilia you know when a new
product when a new
um medium comes along we tend to
overweight the things the new medium
allows you to do that the old one didn't
okay and we underweight things that the
old one did that the new one doesn't do
very well it's rather like the Kindle
you know when when the Kindle I naively
said oh this is just going to replace
books
their course doesn't replace books
because okay probably about 40 of books
are bought as gifts in by volume by
value okay
um you know Christmas is a huge swans of
the publishing game the biggest
categories in books are kind of book
cookery gardening lifestyle architecture
that kind of [__] which requires really
high quality photography okay
um so actually you know the Kindle isn't
going to do either of those two jobs
just to just for the off if it's purely
textual
non-fiction reference huge advantages
there if the person buying the book
travels a lot and loves the fact they
can be sitting at 35 000 feet and over
Wi-Fi can buy a copy of a novel
that's miraculous okay I'm don't get me
wrong it's a fantastic advantage over
conventional bugs
but equally
uh we're in danger of throwing the baby
out with a bath water which I think
we're doing with marketing as well to
the same extent we're forgetting what in
other words
being able to measure
and to quantify and to justify your
spend in Direct Media which was always
what made them different to some extent
there was a direct attributable
measurement of Behavioral change as a
result of your particular
um uh your particular piece of stimulus
and okay
um
uh actually by the way it was not nearly
as direct and attributable because
obviously if you're doing direct
marketing for a strong brand like
American Express which is a big
Advertiser you've got to proportionately
much bigger response than if you're
advertising for someone on behalf of
someone they've never heard of so it was
a bit of a nonsense to claim that the uh
the you know the value of the of the
acquisition was entirely attributable to
the letter you sent the customer okay
um but nonetheless unit that
measurability was valuable but
unfortunately people have got so
obsessed with it that they're now unable
to do anything that you can't perfectly
quantify yeah and actually there are
quite a lot of valuable marketing
activities which I would argue are
actually probabilistic you know you just
make a load of noise because I can't
tell to a great degree of exactitude who
my customers are going to be in five
years time
so the best thing I can do is make sure
they've heard of me so that should they
enter the market for the product I sell
they at least consider what I have to
provide yeah okay and it's going
backwards in other words let's not try
and find the customers let's make sure
the customers know a lot of enough about
us that they'll come and find us and
they're complementary by the way you
know you can do both they're not
mutually exclusive
but because the one is where it's harder
to measure and slower to reveal its
results than the other we've
disproportionately favored what's
quantifiable over what's important
because it's quantification bias again
it's that same thing all over again
sometimes called the um
who the hell was the guy who kind of um
was behind the Vietnam War metrics in
the Vietnam War which it's occasionally
called I'll remember his name in a
second
um the problem it creates there are many
many long-term things which will never
be measurable or attributable simply
because in between the initial stimulus
and the eventual purchase
too much happens I mean famously someone
said to Jeremy bullmore they said um the
great wonderful advertising Guru who
died earlier this year at 92. they said
you know I've just born Aston Martin it
won't surprise you to know I bought the
Aston Martin as a result of an
advertisement I saw what may surprise
you is I saw that advertisement when I
was 12 years old
okay and so you know a large part of
this stuff is probabilistic oh but the
perfect demonstration of this to me was
if I'd sat down and said who is the
target audience for my book Alchemy I
would have defined it in terms of people
interested in marketing people
interested in Psychology people
interested in Behavioral Science and
those people it's true are
disproportionately interested in this
kind of thing but outside those areas of
interest there are probably another
million people who would be who would
quite enjoy reading the book out of
curiosity and one day it was June I
think in about 2018 if I got this right
well I mean yeah
um I appear on the Chris Evans breakfast
show audience around a million people
and Chris Evans interviews me about the
book
um uh and you know I've a reasonably
good account of things what I didn't
know is that Chris then went to the
beach because it was being broadcast
from Cairns in the advertising festival
and one of Chris's assistants had just
read the book and said Chris you'll like
this and this guy's probably in can
because he works in advertising the
following day which I didn't know
because I was pottering around obviously
not listening to Virgin because I was in
France okay Chris had finished the book
and was raving about it quoting from it
and everything else
the first I got to know about this was I
went on to Amazon to look at the sales
ranking okay
and I was outside I outsold JK Rowling
for about a week I also I couldn't
outsell the book of nom
um I answered the highway code and I
sold the hungry little caterpillar for a
day I think okay
um okay uh but what was interesting was
that this was internally the results of
the radio program reaching audiences you
in other words you never would have
defined in advance okay I mean I think I
was number eight on Amazon overall for a
few days
and I suddenly realized okay you know
there are two directions this is what
bees do you know there's exploit explore
there's we know where the pollen is
let's go and get more of it and there's
this supply of pollen
um is not the sum total of available
resources we need to explore elsewhere
partly to Future proof The Hive against
you know a sudden depletion of your
existing Supply okay and partly by the
way just for the chance of getting lucky
you know if you don't actually invest a
certain amount in explore rather than
exploit you'll never have a kind of big
Bonanza upside discovery
you'll never have a pleasant surprise
you'll only have nasty surprises yeah
which is interesting because when you
think about it most businesses are
optimized around exploit yeah once they
pass the entrepreneurial phase it's okay
we know what we're doing now let's just
do more of it more efficiently and in
the short term of course it's great but
you know if you got rid of the random
bees who troll around looking for pollen
at random yep in the short term you're
pulling a nectar collection figures
would look more impressive the problem
is is that it's downhill from there on
you can't cost cut your way to growth
putting it another way alrighty so on
this point about kind of defining your
audience
um we were having honestly like sort of
before you came here we were having a
bit of a dilemma we're trying to figure
out like who is the target audience for
a conversation like this and then that
goes thinking who's a target audience
for the podcast because we have like an
average of like who I kind of think is
the person who watches watches the
podcast which is probably male probably
in the west probably a few years younger
than Mima so maybe in like early to mid
20s probably has like a normal job
normal job uh probably is Keen to start
some kind of side hustle because they
like the idea of financial Independence
but that's like we have a huge audience
on the YouTube channel on the podcast
which is all of the world around about
60 40 male female like all sorts of age
groups people from you know I get emails
from people who are in their 60s who
listen to the podcast oh absolutely yeah
like so any any ideas on on how to
strike this balance between it's worth
defining a target audience versus it's
not worth defining a target audience one
thing that people get muddled up with is
user imagery versus target audience
because
if you look at ads for small cars they
will almost certainly share the car
being driven around by a sort of 32 year
old 28 year old typically female
person which is the user imagery okay
overwhelmingly all new cars are bought
by the relatively elderly all cars
bought from new I think the average age
of a Volkswagen buyer is probably about
54. oh wow a new Volkswagen I mean
you know I I've only had two new no I
only had one new car in my entire life
in fact I'm 57 okay maybe I had two okay
now the difference there is that
um
if there are some wealthy uh you know 28
year old females who are buying brand
new Peugeot you know 20 whatevers okay
now the reason you use them as the user
imagery is if you show 27 year old girls
driving the car
um 58 year old or 64 year old retirees
don't mind buying it but if you show the
car being driven by 65 year olds you'll
entirely lose your 28 year old audience
so there's a kind of interesting idea of
who you're talking to
okay or who you feature is your user
imagery
but that don't let don't ever get
confused that that's actually your
target audience
ah okay okay and actually by the way if
you look at the work of Byron sharp uh
if you look at the marketing work of
um uh also probably Mark richson and
other people but also Bennett and field
I'm quoting sort of uh pretty good
academics
uh most most brands have actually bought
as part of a repertoire and what
distinguishes leading Brands is that
more people buy them sometimes and the
people who buy them sometimes tend to
buy them more often
sorry more people buy them sometimes
yeah so okay I've got a perfect
expression of this which is my favorite
end line of all time in advertising
which is the most interesting man in the
world for Dos Equis who says I do not
always drink beer but when I do I prefer
Dos Equis
stay thirsty my friend he's got a
Hemingway as character okay now because
the most interesting man in the world
wouldn't only drink beer okay and he
wouldn't even stick to one brand of beer
but what he does is he doesn't always
drink beer but when he does drink beer
he tends to drink Dos Equis and if you
have more of those people than your
competitors then you're the leading
brand it's not a matter of perfect
loyalty so it's like
exactly yeah
it's important actually to understand
these things I mean one of the things I
don't think is understood as well is
that um
one thing that's increasingly
interesting me
is what are the products
that nobody wants but that once you've
experienced them they fundamentally
um create a convert or a even an
evangelist Japanese toilet seats you've
got an exactly Japanese title to one
airfryers probably another okay where
weirdly nobody wants the thing everybody
is what the hell are you talking about
and then anybody who owns one of the
people who own them about 50 of people
effectively become swivel evangelize
that's why I bought an air fryer and it
occurred to me that one of the important
roles of advertising and by the way this
is much much easier for products you use
frequently than products you use
infrequently one of the things I was
watching
um on YouTube
little little listener tip YouTube
premium nobody has it but it's the best
value thing you've ever buy incredible
okay ad free YouTube we didn't we didn't
buy it when YouTube first came out
because YouTube was full of slightly
grainy shot on a wobbly phone you know
kind of low resolution stuff I mean huge
swings of it are now kind of 4K
broadcast quality watch it on their
55-inch Kelly and it's only a year or
two away from becoming Wikipedia with
video
because the volume of what's on YouTube
is now so unbelievably kind of
comprehensive that actually you can use
YouTube pretty much in the way that you
use Wikipedia in fact okay
um but anyway sorry part that
um I was watching a YouTube video which
was a kind of cut down of the Dragon's
Den which for American listeners is
known as shark tank in the U.S
and it featured the
the worst mistakes that the dragons had
made okay the trunky suitcase the ride
on suitcase was one okay I can't
remember the other one but the most
egregious one was effectively a a brand
called Hungry House which ended up being
sold to a German company and then sold
to to just eat for I think 220 million
pounds okay so missing that was clearly
a mistake okay
and they were all Heavy arguments this
is this exactly back to this point about
the uh is it a hundred people doing is
it 100 people doing something once or is
it one person doing something a hundred
times okay
and I I kind of went and analyzed this
by the way I don't want you want you to
think that I regard you know dragging
the stand or The Apprentice as somehow
emblematic of business they're
extraordinary ridiculous I mean I I
worry about it actually the extent to
which most people's view of free market
capitalism must be colored by the
dragons 10 of The Apprentice oh yeah
which are you know absurd I mean in many
ways okay they're wonderful but they're
absurd I mean we uh just on that no um
the person we interviewed last week um
made it to the final like 10 for The
Apprentice but they said her business
plan was too good and she should just
get investment and start a business
which she did uh rather than actually
winning the program yeah because because
it said to her look we're gonna be
honest the show is entertainment your
business plan is too good uh so just
execute on that and so she wasn't on the
show brilliant now the interesting thing
there is that
I Look to this look how did you miss it
and they were having an argument with
Deborah Mead and having an argument with
you know
um I I think it was Valentine about you
know now bear in mind this was in the
late 90s early 2000s there was an
argument about whether people would
actually order takeaway food for
delivery or collection over the web at
all okay
sounds ridiculous now but there was an
early attempt to do pizza ordering
online in the late 90s which failed
because people said well I just pick up
the phone because their level of
confidence in it was so low that you'd
typically order your pizzas online and
then ring up the pizza place to go did
you get my internet order okay well
that's clearly not a benefit to anybody
okay
but anyway it's something occurred to me
that the question they failed to ask the
people who are running hungry house
which was the only question that
mattered was this when people use your
product or service once do they go on
using it
or a secondary question which may be a
catch you know a kind of safety net when
people use your product three times do
they go on using it in other words now
this comes to a fairly philosophical
point in both economics and anything
else okay which is that there are
certain things which it is pointless to
speculate about in advance because the
act of owning them or using them
fundamentally changes your utility
function and your preferences okay now
the most extreme case and Russ Roberts
of the utterly brilliant um econ Talk
podcast
okay Russ Roberts talked about this
having children okay from the point of
view of a single couple or a single
person it's an utterly stupid decision
having children okay because all the
things you enjoy as a single person
become either impossible or really
expensive you know every time you stay
in a hotel you're paying for two rooms
out of one salary when you were paying
for one remote or two salaries so now
staying at the Travel Lodge is probably
more expensive than staying at the
Intercontinental before you can't go out
to nightclubs without getting
babysitting all the [__] you really
enjoy is more or less destroyed and the
buggers are really really expensive okay
it's a terrible decision having children
except for the fact that once you have
children thanks to evolutionary
psychology all your preferences your
priorities and your idea of utility
completely changes okay so that those
things become comparatively much less
important and the you know the
well-being and happiness of your
children become correspondingly more
important now
Alexander slightly banal level a
Japanese toilet is the same okay the
until you've actually tried it once
you've tried a Japanese toilet okay
going back to a basic Western toilet is
as yawning a golf as going through a
western dry wipe toilet to [__] in a
hole in the garden that's that's about
their comparative distance in terms of
perception okay
um now similarly an air fryer once
you've had it no going multi-channel TV
mobile phone probably the electric car
interestingly now it strikes me that one
of the things we fail to do with a lot
of.com ideas
is ask how frequently will this be used
because those things mobile phone
multi-channel TV electric car air fryer
up Japanese toilet are all things which
by definition assuming you've got
reasonable bowel Health you're going to
use every day okay at least every two
days okay all right now those things
change your fundamentally if you do
something differently frequently I park
a lot at the station so the parking app
kind of changes my whole view of parking
okay
um if you only Park once a year I would
argue that you know actually a a parking
app is a pain in the ass okay yes if you
only if you only actually Park in a
station car park once a year the fact
that you now have to
um use now to part there for my dad who
doesn't even have a smartphone it's
actually uh uh a complete obstacle for
other people it's a monstrous pain yeah
by the way we're not treating the
elderly very well with tech
okay we are absolutely Tech should be
enabling people to stay in their homes
for longer and if anything it's creating
actually uh you know unbelievable
obstacles remember my dad was selling
books in his mid to late 80s was selling
books on Amazon okay he's not a techno
um lug out by any means but he says at
the age of 92 he said I've just got to a
point where resetting my password is it
doesn't say mind [__] but that's what he
means okay
and um you know we haven't we haven't
thought those things through adequately
at all but that frequency thing really
interests me because I see a lot of.com
ideas and I go this is a great idea in
theory but actually it's a it's it's a
hundred thousand people doing something
once yep what you really need is
actually to get something started it's
uh 10 000 people doing something once a
week or once a day
because rather like having children
those are the things where once to quote
the the Vauxhall end line of the 2000s
Once Driven forever smitten that the act
of owning it of doing it nobody in
Britain wanted multi-channel TV back in
the um 80s and 90s there was a stupid
American thing they're just a load of
rubbish on you know what's wrong with
four channels yeah okay but nobody who
had multi-channel TV ever went back and
I don't think we asked this question
what I might call the the longitudinal
question nearly enough because
everybody's looking at the self the
aggregate sales figures for electric
cars
okay
the real question you need to ask if you
want to predict where the Market's going
is of the people who buy electric cars
how many of them revert hmm
in other words this is a one-way Street
where once owned your fundamental
preferences are so Changed by the
experience of the alternative one thing
I always thought was a bit like that if
I'm being absolutely candid about it
which had a lot of resistance but nobody
ever went back was driving an automatic
okay okay loads of bridges bollocks no
it's the sense of control you know all
that sort of stuff now the reason Brits
didn't drive automatics was that
many Americans sorry many British cars
of the 50s and 60s were so bloody weedy
okay you needed a manual transmission
just to get up a bloody Hill okay and
also automatics only had typically three
speeds now big American V8 had no
trouble handling that but a Morris Minor
would have basically ground to a halt
good bit of trivia by the way
the Morris Minor
um if I've got this right engine the
1200 cc probably engine was also the
starter motor
um for the Centurion tank
okay so
it was Sophie it was so fever
when he put it in a tank it was merely
the starter vote yeah but um
but actually Everybody Talks this crap
about automatics but everybody who
drives an automatic goes well stop that
manual for a game of soldiers you know
very you know because they know me wrong
if I lived in the north of Scotland just
off the A9 okay and I had long glorious
winding open roads I'd probably revert
to a manual for the pleasure of kind of
you know you know gear changing and
control most of my driving is either on
a Motorway where you just drive along at
a constant speed or I'm stuck in traffic
yeah now in both those situations or
actually even more extreme I'm
maneuvering in a car park where I much
prefer the creep that you enjoy through
an automatic because you can maneuver at
very slow speeds without running over
dogs and things okay
now you know I think that's typical case
where nobody wants it but once you've
experienced it what you want
fundamentally changes so there's
probably an important role for
advertising in just generating trial and
accelerating take up because the two big
forces in human instinct are social
copying do what everybody else does and
habit do what I've done before
okay yep and as a result Behavior change
tends to take on a sigmoid curve shape
and it occurred to me that people who
don't know this
may have been writing off lots of
products too early because they failed
to realize that most new significant
ideas are very slow to take off at the
beginning and there were mobile phones
in Britain in the 1970s my father's
business partner had one uh where you
basically radioed a great big aerial and
you said can you please put me through
to
raglan201 and someone put but it was a
Carphone okay
and so those things existed for years
and then okay part of it was
technological Improvement part of it was
just people that experienced them people
who a year earlier and said why would I
want to make a phone call in the street
I used a mobile phone in Oxford Street
1989 two people rolled down the windows
of taxis and shouted abuse at me oh well
okay 1989 someone's visibly using a
mobile phone on Oxford Street you know
this wasn't in the depths of the
countryside where they thought it was
witchcraft the Oxford Street and they
actually pulled down a taxi window when
wanker okay yeah right now that it was
only okay it was seven years before you
know to take that technology to the
mainstream yep
I think they they bailed on Google Glass
much too early for example yeah you know
four years later three years later I
would have been pissed in the airport
and I would have just bought bought it
you know and I you know I think it's
very important we realized this because
if you think that adoption of things is
linear you will often give up too soon
the question you need to ask is not how
fast are we growing it's how sticky is
this product yep
um what are your thoughts on
brand redesigns
because we're having this issue well
yeah a bit of an issue right now in that
for the YouTube channel and for the
podcast and stuff we've done a bit of a
Rebrand and I think I think the new one
looks pretty sick but there's a lot of
people on our team being like oh it
doesn't look as friendly or as nice as
like the old one did and it strikes me
that I remember is there a recognizable
line from one to the other is this a
refresh or a complete Rebrand
um I think there's a little bit of a
recognizable line it's like okay I can
see that this is this Rebrand or
refreshes uh sort of making everything a
little bit more consistent as previously
it was a bit of a hodgepodge of
different things
and it kind of got me thinking about
well back when Facebook was a thing
really careful by the way because the
extent to which we select icons and
often we select a podcast through a kind
of Icon okay
the extent to which that's an
unconscious thing yeah which will be
completely you know kai boshed by by too
great a change of color yeah you've got
I think you've got to be really God I'm
careful there um particularly given the
kind of choice architecture around which
podcast should I listen to now yep
um so you know you might want to look at
a migrate a slower migration and it's
always notable that at no point does
anybody come although I think it's
becoming increasingly a terrible sight
by the way no one's ever turned up at
the Amazon website and thought what the
hell's going on here yeah okay you know
that the whole thing has been an
evolution very slow changes over time I
think I think if I'm right they
basically allow which is a mistake by
the way they allow algorithms pretty
much to determine the site now so
there's continuous testing on the
background of small things
mean that there is ultimately the
opportunity for someone to come along
and completely wrong foot them I mean it
always baffles me by the way that uh
that Shopify hasn't created a search
engine
yeah they really should it's not weird
isn't it yeah I did ask the guy once
they said oh we it would be unfair
because it would mean we're
discriminating between our customers and
I thought well the customers would much
prefer to get five times the business
and for a competitor to get seven times
the business with them to stay along in
this kind of you know in what you might
call egalitarian obscurity like it's so
nice when something is on Shopify and
has shop pay as an option card details
say oh it's almost you it's almost
easier than Amazon at that point but
also also the ability to select by
um I mean this is something that's
really fascinating the whole question of
choice architecture is one of the really
really robust findings of Behavioral
Science
and the way you present a choice to
people okay uh will and the order in
which they're asked to eliminate things
by attribute okay will have an enormous
effect on what they end up choosing okay
what do you mean the order in which that
right
well an example would be
um
let's imagine okay we bought art the way
we bought property so alongside say
prime location or right move there was a
thing called right art okay
and he went I'd like something about
five feet by three feet
um featuring two goats and a cow uh
mostly blue but with a smattering of
Pinks okay between these two price
points yeah okay
in that world Picasso's will be really
cheap because they'd hardly ever show up
yeah okay and now obviously we don't buy
art like that but is it right that we
buy property with Aesthetics and Design
because they're harder to quantify so
far down the decision tree that all you
end up doing is you go location price
number of bedrooms number of bedrooms a
terrible metric by the way because it
means that every single person dealing
property has an incentive to provide
lots of totally tiny bedrooms okay and
as a result we have too few toilets two
through bathrooms uh you know and
instead of having whatever he has needs
actually is one really big room okay
right
instead of that you know you have you
have too many rooms that are too small
and too few rooms that aren't bedrooms
arguably okay and so that's a distortion
I mean in Europe in the US they tend to
do it by square footage or square meter
Ridge
but then okay what if you what if you
changed things now okay there's a
website that does this the modern
house.net okay and the modern house.net
basically makes some sort of
architectural distinction
a prerequisite for appearing on the site
yeah
now if you had a Parker score for this
is my weird observation that
architecture is the cheapest way to buy
art because really good architecture for
a given location and size of property
only adds about one or two percent to
the price of a house
Place actually at the isocon up in
Hampstead I think it's one bedroom flat
uh absolute you know kind of a modernist
Masterpiece okay uh there's a place near
Tunbridge for sale which is actually by
gropius and Frye no premium as far as I
can see over any House nearby now you
know that's weird right okay
I don't seems weird to me that you know
people will pay an enormous amount of
money to own a painting by a great
artist compared to an indifferent artist
I live in the roof of a Robert Adam
house my next door neighbor in the flat
next door is an economist I said how
much do we actually pay as a premium for
the fact that this is a Robert Adam
house uh rather than just some random
piece of [__] of the same location he
said I wondered about that he said
somewhere between naught and two percent
now that's crazy right
because presumably Aesthetics you know
unless I'm wrong about everything
Aesthetics and design can contribute
quite significantly to happiness yeah
we'd much rather own a house or you
could argue by the way the right the
best measure on right move would be how
attractive the house opposite is because
that's what you're looking at yeah okay
I lived in Westbourne Park Villas when I
first moved to London in a place back
backing onto the Paddington railway
tracks which was to be honest a bit of a
[__] but we woke up in the morning
and looked at a sort of one million
pound house on Westbourne Park Villas
and I always felt sorry for them because
they'd paid 1.4 million pounds to look
at us
um but what I'm saying is that in many
cases the way we choose is based on kind
of arbitrary
um you know
I mean one of the most peculiar things
that's happening in property at the
moment by the way
uh is that you must never ever try and
sell a house for 675 000 pounds because
all the property websites have at that
price point it's 650 700 000 I think it
might be six hundred thousand I I 700
000 but I think they stop at fifty
thousand increments if you price your
house at 25 you're in between two and so
the people searching uh 600 and up or
the people searching 650 and down are
less likely to find you yeah and so your
house won't sell so now you don't have a
price demand curve you have a price
demand ziggurat yeah okay that's the
example of how how you present choice
will distort a market
okay the Reason by the way these Amazon
brands are all called Lulu Amazon
Marketplace Brands right do you know why
no why that because okay geez I'm
thinking I'm going to emigrate to
Shanghai and just become a branding
expert by saying next time rather than
using a set of Scrabble tiles to name
your brand why you actually have
something that's memorable and suggests
you're actually on the business of
building a brand reputation rather than
just using random vowels and consonants
like a really bad round of countdown
okay you know our vowel please Carol
another vowel and another vowel okay
okay Carol I said Carol oh my God
okay it's Rachel's no sorry
um now
here's what's really weird about this
okay which is that the algorithm gives
priority to
Brands inverted commas
which are trademarked in the U.S it's
much easier and much faster to trademark
a random collection of consonants and
vowels than it is to Trump if I tried to
trademark you know Sutherland camping
equipment okay it would probably take me
ages and then some lawyer would pitch up
from [__] Wyoming going there's a Mr
Sutherland here who runs a [__] tent
shop you know you know you just imagine
the whole thing okay whereas if it's
extremely unlikely anybody's going to
challenge your right to call yourself
right yeah so all they're doing is
creating a name that's really easy to
legally trademark so they can game the
algorithm it's not in the interest of
the consumer at all right what's in the
interest of the consumers recognizable
brand names like you know even if
they're Amazon Brands like anchor or
whatever or green which we can buy more
of if we like what we buy and buy less
of if we don't like it brands are
basically the units of selection in The
evolutionary Marketplace which is
consumer capitalism okay and a brand
name allows you collectively and
individually to reward a good experience
with future business and to punish a bad
experience with a future boycott so
anybody who's interested in the
longevity of their business will try and
live up to their promises if that
promise is attached to a brand okay if
that promise is attached to you right
you won't because you've got no
investment in that you it's just one of
47 other Scrabble tiles that you've got
now this fact that brands are actually
essential to the workings of consumer
capitalism because they're the units of
selection is totally overlooked as far
as I can see Brands actually lead to
better products the absence of Brands
often destroys markets because nobody
can confidently make a decision yeah
within them okay
and
it strikes me that Amazon by making that
thing is it a registered trademark
rather than is it actually a
pronounceable word okay is doing a
complete disservice it's it's it's
contributing to the I think I think if I
run Curry doctor calls the
insidification
you know various people started writing
the Atlantic about something I noticed
about a year and a half ago which is
that quite a lot of mainstream massive
things Google Facebook Amazon which for
the first 15 years were extremely
admirable okay have started to get worse
yep
Google started to get worse because uh
patently the ads used to be on the right
and the and the native search used to be
on the left now if you try and find out
the phone number of a hotel it's a
living bloody nightmare right because 76
competing hotels will start appearing
all over the place right that's in
shitification because it's moved from
serving the consumer to serving The
Advertiser and then eventually you stop
serving evenly advertisers and you just
start serving yourself
uh Amazon I think you know if I search
for Samsung televisions mate okay
imagine a human being I go into couriers
right now I'd like to look at Samsung
televisions please now here's perfect
Liberty to say well if I were you I'd
have a deco at LG as well okay that's
within his rights as an expert salesman
perhaps
but okay if I search for Samsung
televisions I expect my search to
include some Samsung televisions how
[__] ridiculous it's hardly you know
too much to ask is it right I feel like
when a lot of people hear the word
marketing or advertising they're
immediately there it gets the hackles up
because it feels sales mini and even the
word sales feels like evil in some way
how like as someone who's worked in
marketing for the last like
40 years or so like what's what's your
take on why that is the funny thing is
what's going on there the bits of
advertising that really annoy people
mostly are produced by advertising
agencies so if you get the accusation it
makes people want things they don't need
well that's a bit of a complex Point
anyway because on an average day a human
being needs about 1500 calories okay
um you know I don't know 120 liters of
air and a warp dry place okay everything
else is a want at some level okay so the
whole thing about one I mean it's very
interesting by the way to read
um there was a left-wing
anti-advertising pamphlet from the 1960s
and it said you know in many ways
advertising has obviated many of the
Great achievements that we've had in
enriching the working class because it
turns out that the working class just
spend their money on pointless luxuries
wait for this okay like washing machines
okay let me hold on a second okay if
you're a working class family of 1960
your mum would have had some sort of tub
mechanism with a mangle and a whole day
of her life would have been spent doing
the household laundry and yet you're
referring to a washing machine as a
pointless luxury you know this is a you
know I mean
it's worth noting that what you know
what you know in the 1960s a washing
machine was seen as a massive
extravagance you see and therefore for
some reason the working classes weren't
supposed to buy them I mean how
outrageous kind of nonsense so anyway
never mind we've got to ask this
question of what's a want and what's a
need most of the luxury good stuff is
done in-house
and quite a bit of it is done to keep
luxury goods Publications happy it's not
only to reach the consumer it's also to
ensure if you advertise extensively in
fashion Publications you'll get featured
a bit more okay so that all kinds of
other things going on for example the
vast majority of my time which hasn't
been in B2B marketing some of some of it
has the vast majority of my time spent
in advertising has been
um uh uh okay promoting Broadband for BT
promoting the American Express card
early on
um uh promoting vaping or alternatives
to smoking okay so any form of
Behavioral change whether for good or
bad does require
um communication yeah okay it's you know
at the very least it might happen anyway
but it'll happen more slowly if you
don't advertise it for example
and um uh you know actually most
advertising now is compare the meerkat
you know okay there's a certain amount
for alcohol there's a certain amount
from you know luxury goods what
advertising agencies are mostly doing is
by the way most people in our agencies
lean left wing by the way you wouldn't
expect this in drama in kind of you know
in in the kind of what you might call
the dramatic depiction of an ad agency
it's not a cynical right-wing bastards
most people are pink I mean most people
you know most of my young colleagues are
way to the left of me and generally they
don't have a problem with what they're
selling you know even gen Z go okay you
know okay electric cars another thing
I've been engaged in you know so that
now that's interesting because
in the electric car world for example
let's look at it as a category not just
as individual brands
to an enormous extent okay range anxiety
which is the big obstacle and the thing
now individual brands are always talking
about range because that's the thing
they've got to actually convince the
consumer about and that's how they
compete with other electric car brands
the only problem is that the universal
conversation about range is actually in
a sense creating a fear or magnifying
Affair that doesn't need to be that
present okay now let me explain why
okay so I don't have car charging at
home I'm going to get it but I haven't
got around to it my wife has a mini
electric which has about 100 miles range
I've got the Ford Mustang Mackie which
has about 250 the extended range okay
what I suddenly realized once you own an
electric car and once you actually
overcome this anxiety is that now this
wouldn't be true okay just be just to
care about it if you lived in an obscure
part of North Wales or somewhere weird
in Scotland this may not be true but for
most Brits most of the time range
anxiety is a perfectly rational American
fare which doesn't apply to the UK
really okay not a very big country okay
you know
in in America it's not uncommon for your
parents to live 400 miles away okay and
you've got to go and visit them over a
weekend because let's face it you get no
bloody vacation okay right that that's
better if I'm an American okay my plan
to stand for president United States
Islamic benefit I wasn't born there
although funnily enough Woodrow Wilson
is something like my second cousin his
mum was born in in England he's actually
my second cousin three times removed or
something as bit of a freak
um but all I stand on is a platform of
four weeks paid vacation I wouldn't
bother with any of the other stuff we're
talking electric cars range anxiety
electric cars so we've got trains as an
alternative I had to go to Manchester
for the day I wouldn't drive anyway okay
I had to go to Manchester overnight I
probably wouldn't drive okay you've got
to go to Manchester for five days I
wouldn't drive but then it's a leisurely
trip up and I'm going to stop somewhere
and you know go and visit a country
house or something or you know whatever
okay
and I'm going to find somewhere to
charge and also uh I can't in the UK
driving traffic density being sounds you
can't really drive for three hours
without taking a break anyway it's not
healthy or sensible to do it you can on
the interstate in the US because it's
just such a chill experience by contrast
secondly when I get to my dad's house
he's got 240 volts now it's not seven
kilowatts but it's three three and a
half and actually if I arrive with a 50
tank and I plug in to his ordinary
outdoor socket I'll be up to about 85 by
the time I leave in the morning okay
well that's way more than enough to get
me to the next rapid charger should I
need one
we don't have really extreme cold very
often okay uh as I said we've got three
kilowatts at home we have the
alternative of a train we don't do very
long drives and also this is a very high
density country so in the US you need
gas stations to serve at geography not
just a population
okay because if you're halfway between
say teos New Mexico and Farmington if
you don't have a gas station somewhere
on Route nobody can actually make the
journey okay now in the UK I went to
check this out okay the UK has about 8
500 petrol stations in the US they've
got about 116 000. and the reason they
need a multiplier more proportional to
the population is because of the
geographical coverage yep
now in the UK it's not like oh [__]
we're on the I-40 between so and so and
so and so and if the next charge is out
of action we're basically going to have
to spend the night in an Idaho truck
normal I-40 is it okay I don't want
those I buy something else 80 I don't
know okay you know I'm gonna have to
spend the night in an Idaho truck stop
in the freezing cold while the radio
tells the sort of serial killers just
escape the local Penitentiary okay in
Britain it would be oh dear this charger
is broken oh look there's another one
two miles down the road next to a tea
shop so we'll stock up on scones and
bums okay uh while the car's charging
yeah
it's a different kind of thing okay
you're not in the middle of nowhere in
Britain
um okay and so actually what we've done
is we've imported Affair into the
Netherlands and the UK in particular
which is perfectly relevant to Americans
and I I get it okay actually in the UK
down that okay I've got I've got a cafe
with a charger 50 feet away rapid
charger I've got a waitrose with a
couple of them I've got a Tesco with a
couple of slow Chargers I've got an
Indian restaurant with a rapid actually
that's all you need actually an Indian
restaurant a rapid charge a job done
yeah
how do we get to this
um we were talking cars I was talking
about that ratchet effect where you know
one important thing is there are
products which actually change your
whole yes your whole outlook so once
experienced actually your entire kind of
preferences and utility function gets
reset yep because they experience
effectively rage eggs in your mind
what's important yeah yeah yeah and
we're also talking about kind of
advertising and marketing being seen in
back oh yes yeah yeah and and so you've
said that
yeah I've spent most of my you know I I
don't really I'm I'm very very proud of
the work on vaping by the way
oh that was probably the most you know
most valuable thing I did in my life was
going to the government's behavioral
insights team and saying they're these
things coming along called electronic
cigarettes one because they mimic the
habit and experience of smoking they're
probably a major Gateway off cigarettes
okay two
three and this was actually the more
important psychological insight my hunch
is that almost everybody in the health
in what you might call the the health
industry is going to try and ban them
okay yeah okay
what I would say is go to the Garden
they did this David Halpin went to what
was then the Cameron government and said
we think these electronic cigarettes are
going to be useful rather than you know
or at least it's harm reduction whose
benefits outweigh the costs let's put it
like that okay yep
okay it's not perfect perfect is
everybody going cold turkey I get that
but the perfect is often the enemy of
the good and actually the UK and Sweden
which have the lightest touch regulation
on Alternatives in Sweden of course it's
the pouches that nicotine pouches they
put in there which to be honest give me
the shits but I mean they're they're
pretty potent uh but but in in the UK it
tends to be very liberal approach to
e-cigarettes and vaping yeah and those
two countries seem to have the lowest
rate of smoking in Europe
so you know there is you know okay
correlation is not all that but
um that was the one thing where you know
of all the things I did in my life which
was probably valuable I think it was
that how how do you feel about the sort
of you've talked I think in alchemy and
some other things around psychological
value
um and almost drives me like
psychological value
the fact that we're calling it
psychological almost makes it distinct
from actual value
um what's your what's your technology
it's completely wrong because if you're
if you're an Austrian School Economist
value is all psychological the only
definition of value they accept is your
willingness to pay for something
and they also argue that um
interestingly this is why Austrian
school economics never got mathematical
because just for As a detail they also
argue that
um actually preference is ordinal not
Cardinal okay what does that mean well
okay
so
they would they would look at a choice
in the oxygen school and say you prefer
an iPhone over an Android phone okay
um they would now economics in order to
have this idea of utility has to have
the idea that you actually value the uh
the the iPhone at 1.374 times more
highly than the equivalently priced
other phone okay okay now Austrian
school economics at least Ludwig Van me
as it says it's a nonsense you either
prefer it or you don't that's what
determines your behavior it's a nonsense
to actually suggest that we're going
around optimizing all the time uh for
um uh you know our utility function sure
like the sorts of people that would
spend 18 hours researching a phone might
care about the Snapdragon processor but
most people don't no no absolutely and
and that those are that's an interesting
question which is the misalignment often
between the metrics which phone
developers or technologists pursue which
tend to be SI derived units like speed
time process of power what is it flops
or something is it yeah okay whatever
okay and the actual consumer experience
what the consumer wants yeah I'm sorry
to bore people who've heard me before
but I always cite the Uber map as a work
of psychological genius which is that
yes we prefer taxis to turn up earlier
rather than later I buy that but within
a reasonable marginal era like the
difference in five minutes or ten
minutes or the difference between 7
minutes and 12 minutes what we actually
care about much more than punctuality is
actually uncertainty yep
and what the map does is it doesn't
necessarily it doesn't reduce the
quantity of wait time it transforms the
quality of wait time but as we're no
longer in a state of not knowing a state
of panic a state of what if he's already
left I bet they were lying they always
lie oh they probably haven't sent a taxi
at all and it replaces it with oh look
there he is I guess you'll be here in
another three minutes I'll have another
pint that's probably another half okay
and so you know and so that's a
beautiful beautiful case of literally
Conjuring up emotional value out of
nowhere now you could do a predictive
algorithm which Roots cars to where you
anticipate high demand but there are
downsides to that it's expensive to do
it requires a large amount of scale to
do it and also what I suspect would
happen if you did that is every time you
got it wrong and you sent a driver to a
place where there was no demand they'd
get really pissed off you know your
algorithm would say oh there's a
fantastic nightclub there and there's
always a lot of demand at two o'clock in
the morning right but you know they're
closed for repairs right and so suddenly
17 taxis are sent some weird alien Shore
ditch at two o'clock in the morning and
there's nobody there okay they're not
going to be happy
the map's perfect because actually the
one thing they don't have is people
ringing them up going where the hell are
you yeah
yeah it's like when you order from
Domino's you can't I don't even think
you get that thing where it's like your
pizzas in the oven when we're now doing
the thing and it probably Bears no
resemblance to reality but
I've learned contrary views about that
some people say that they actually know
the Domino's thing is quite honest right
other people have said that actually
it's kind of I'm there are there are
things which hack a lot of door closed
buttons on elevators
um and I think a lot of buttons on
Pelican Crossings are actually kind of
um placebo buttons yeah they're there to
give you something to do if you're
impatient for the elevator to leave yeah
but they're not actually connected to
anything at all
yeah I find that when I order from
deliveroo or ubereats the fact that like
oh your Rider has arrived at the
restaurant oh you're right it's waiting
it's just sort of those those extra
touch points make me look forward and
anticipate like yeah food's on the way I
don't need to worry yeah
there's a wonderful model by David
rocker neuroscientist called the scarf
model stands for status certainty
autonomy relatedness
call it reciprocality it's probably
better and fairness okay okay
and there are five things
okay
which matter hugely to humans on an
emotional level but which economics
doesn't understand and which we can't
really quantify hmm
and I always joke that the Uber map also
has a small status dimension
which is that I like to time my
departure from the building onto the
sidewalk to coincide exactly
particularly if it's Uber Lux by the way
to coincide exactly with the card
drawing up because it makes me feel like
Kaiser Soze at the end of The Usual
Suspects you know yeah it makes you feel
like Louis XIV you know it makes you
feel walking out of a building and
having a car draw up feels really cool
standing in the rain going I wonder
which of these is my car or maybe none
of them you know you wouldn't get Snoop
doing that would you you know right and
so there are other details and I think
there's a little bit of affiliate when
you just get out of the car without
having to do any transactions yeah
thanks very much feels like a chauffeur
rather than a taxi yeah
um changing it a little bit uh one thing
that I heard you briefly mention in one
of your talks is
kind of the psychology of happiness and
it strikes me that you come across at
least as a very kind of tea cheery kind
of guy not always
um but at least I guess in the public uh
the the the public perception um what
are your thoughts on I guess how the
lessons from the world of advertising
and marketing can be applied to
Something like Happiness I think by the
way when you first start seeing the
world as a complex system
rather than the kind of deterministic
mechanistic thing
I think it makes you happier in the long
term but sad in the short term
okay because
you know I was cast into account of
depression when I first read things like
the selfish Gene
[__] this is actually plausible it
really is just that [__] random okay
um you know uh you know there is no
particular narrative Arc that's actually
you know or or as someone said you know
a very very profound but seemingly banal
statement about evolutionary biology
which is things are the way they are
because they got that way yep
and there isn't necessarily a plan and
actually the needs to see everything
um as purposeful okay probably messes up
economics actually you know because a
very large part of Economics is probably
driven by luck happenstance Serendipity
fluke oh I'll give you what give you an
example penicillin okay the whole of
medicine will probably be different
um
uh if uh by the way you're the real
worry
um of the day the discovery in
penicillin was made
um uh Fleming was kind of working from
home uh he had a cottage somewhere in
Suffolk and wasn't supposed to come into
London that day but happened to go into
London and noticed that all the bacteria
surrounding this patch of random mold
that had blown through the window and
actually died my guess would have been
that he did briefly consider just
chucking it in the bed and starting
again now okay you're saying oh well we
would have discovered penicillin anyway
possibly but there was work at the time
on a thing called I think salt super
sulfides or something which were an
alternative kind of antibacterial agent
without penicillin you know you would
have possibly made enough progress with
those super sulfides okay to stop
looking elsewhere yeah so you know I
mean an awful lot of this [__] really is
that God I'm random I mean God you know
I mean you know Mick and Keith meeting
on a train and what was it I think Mick
happened to have a load of Blues records
which got killed the other way around
got one of them talking to the other
okay
you know the great bands you know what
is it I mean Roxy Music and Brian you
know I think it was a tubes platform
wasn't it
going to the same school you know all
that stuff right I mean a huge amount of
this stuff is spectacularly random and
very very path dependent
you know I mean one of the most
interesting things reading that book by
indoor Harare you know is the view which
I'm not sure about but that actually the
invention of agriculture was kind of a
disaster because it forced everybody
either either get overrun by your
agricultural neighbors who can basically
out populate You by a factor of about 20
or give up enough you know or
effectively get with the agriculture
program and engage in suddenly
hierarchical societies you know all
manner of kind of Oppression and um
control
[Music]
you know it was an arbitrary thing in
the initial evolution of the eye whether
it was convex or concave okay and
insects like flies have a convex
um shape to the eye to give it some sort
of resolution and directional Imaging
and it so happened that you know our
ancestors had a concave shape the
concave shape can evolve into a lens
okay the convex shape never can yeah
so yeah I mean you know when you when
you realize that it is kind of
depressing because you realize there
isn't a kind of you know wig theory of
History where everything gets better and
better and better and actually there's a
whole lot of random [__] going on of you
know I was amazed by the way at the and
I voted to remain but the confidence of
remainers in pronouncing it a bad
decision struck me as I mean you really
know enough about the future to
confidently pronounce this a bad
decision yeah
you know I mean you also look at it by
the way I also made the point okay
let's say you thought the EU was pretty
good as it currently stands okay
but you thought that in the next 20
years very much older people are
slightly more conscious of the direction
of travel of the EU okay because they've
been around for longer they've got more
chronological context let's say you
thought there was a 20 chance that um uh
the EU would morph into something highly
unattractive or inescapable or whatever
you know or just you know
and actually all just to kind of
bureaucratic you know nightmare because
you don't have enough cohesion between
the 27 countries for them ever to get
rid of the governmental class
simultaneously yeah okay in the UK every
10 15 20 years there's kind of political
earthquake same in the U.S okay and the
entire government class gets replaced
yep run out of ideas become corrupt
whatever it may be now that's impossible
in the EU particularly with 27 countries
and and so you know there's the
possibility by the way the idea that
groups of people make better decisions
is is very very unsafe okay there are
all sorts of things like the Abilene
effect where you can get Collective
Insanity where all 27 people go along
with something they don't really agree
with for fear of looking like a party
pooper for example that's called the
Abilene effect you look it up on
Wikipedia so if you thought okay I just
think the EU is a bit dangerous because
everybody in the governmental class is
far too committed to this idea of you
know games to scale
their thoughts you committed often for
status reasons for the idea of general
cosmopolitanism and you know and the
eradication of national boundaries and
differences
then you had to ask the problem okay I
think there's a 20 risk this would
bother me normally but whenever again
will we get a chance to leave yeah and
the likelihood would have been this was
your if you believe that the EU is risky
and might head off somewhere dangerous
you had to ask does it you know if
you're looking at this decision
objectively
um I don't really want to leave now
but I know that it's only a matter of
time before you get a europhile
government which wants to join the Euro
then you know then you can never leave
them
um I don't really want to leave now but
I have to leave now because I have no
idea of the direction of travel of this
vehicle but all I know is this is the
last this is the last station at which I
can get off yeah okay now to make that
decision it's not irrational okay it's
absolutely nonsensical to say that's
irrational you may disagree with it by
the way I'm totally I'm totally happy
listening to both sides of opinion who
acknowledge you know that you know there
is a trade-off involved but this idea
that you were mad racist and horrible
and there was no other possible reason
why you do this yeah those people I mean
I mean genuinely thought you know these
people genuinely are they incapable of
thinking in things in more than one way
in other words are they so infected by
the kind of Davos group think that they
genuinely can envisage no other
alternative future because if that's the
case then I want these people gone you
know I think that's a great place to
wrap this up um final thing I'd love to
ask any book recommendations Lots we've
talking about a few already
um throughout this conversation but
yeah I've just what's what are some
books shot and it's pretty good okay um
uh he's written lots of books about
Behavioral Science if you want to become
a rapid practitioner Richard Shopkins
the first place okay
obviously chaldini Kahneman sailor Etc
the what you might call the Canon of
Behavioral Science
um uh also Dan ariely a lot of these
people hate each other but that's
because they're academics and they're
weird Okay
um you know the whole thing's whack
um
uh the um uh
um uh great book I read recently um I
mean algorithms to live by
um seeing like a state which by the way
I think is also a warning not only to
government that their weird average way
of making the populace comprehensible
actually destroys understanding in the
process I think it has enormous
implications for large.com entities
which is that what happens when the
person
who has the problem the customer who has
the problem fundamentally cannot get in
touch with anybody who has the power to
solve it
okay which you could argue is a little
bit of an argument for brexit but it's
certainly an argument for localism yeah
okay which is actually let's keep the
you know let's maintain this principle
of kind of subsidiarity where decision
making is devolved as low down the
organization as is possible and as close
to the consumer as possible yep okay
um so that's seeing like a state by
James C Scott uh I'm gonna this is going
to be a slight cross-section of
interesting books
what I'm currently listening to is
Drayton Bird's book you did what which
is his life in direct marketing which is
fantastic he's now in his 80s but he was
when I joined Logan made the direct one
of the decisive people in my life other
than my parents a guy in University
who's a mature student called Ray Fouke
who who was studying architecture at
Christ's in the 80s but had previously
been the um uh he and his brothers had
organized the Isle of Wight festivals in
the uh about 60 68 69 70. so when he was
in his early 20s he was kind of
negotiating with Dylan and um you know
the doors and everybody else that
utterly fascinating guy entrepreneur
huge influence but Drake bird was the
third great influence I suppose along
with a few of the other people who are
if you like acolytes of Drayton bird
um but uh he was an extraordinary man
who was the chairman of Oakley and made
the direct when I first joined and was
absolutely you know really fantastic
influence and so I'm just reading his uh
Memoirs at the moment
um I mentioned algorithms to live by in
the alignment problem Uh I that those
are two interesting books I've read
recently there's a great book called
unreasonable Hospitality which has just
come out which is a restaurateur from
New York uh with a very interesting
philosophy on hospitality and or service
um that you know I I'm a big fan by the
way of of effectively as I said the
recurring fractal patterns model of how
life Works reading about a completely
unrelated business uh and saying what is
you know well give me I'll give you an
example of this okay
Airlines have spotted the fact with
loyalty programs and if you're a
frequent flyer uh you're
um utility function if you like your
preferences are different to infrequent
flowers if you're an in-free you fly
once a year actually queuing for eight
minutes to check in isn't that much of a
burden if you fly every week it drives
you insane okay and so they spot
frequent flyers and they treat them
differently
no railway's done this hmm when you
think about it okay now what if you
actually made a third of the carriages
on a typical train or 40 first class
and the people who could use the first
class passenger carriages were people
who bought a first class ticket won
people who had a season ticket who have
more right to a seat than an occasional
traveler okay because having to stand
once every three months is a bit of a
bummer but it's no big deal having to
stand every day for three months is
intolerable you feel totally you know
robbed really okay
anybody with an old person's rail card
and anybody who's a frequent traveler
just gets a slightly better course of
seat okay now the airlines have been
doing that okay so even if you're flying
an economy if you're a frequent flyer
you get the business class experience at
check-in and you get the business class
experience at boarding you know the the
airport and the lounge the airport
experiences business class it's only in
the plane you're in economy okay
that's that's what they've done for ages
with them now nobody now they're not
exactly wildly different Industries
right they're both in transportation but
nobody has asked the question well what
if we could take that and Transplant it
I think there are probably you know I
don't know 10 of businesses out there
that could steal the idea of Amazon
Prime for example
yeah I recently signed up to the prep
coffee subscription ah it's so good so
tell me how it works how much a month
does it so it's 12.50 for the first
month 25 pounds a month thereafter and
you get up to five free coffees every
day
um that can be obviously for your
friends because to fight for yourself it
might be a bit excessive is it uh it can
also be for your friends but yeah
there's got to be at least 30 minutes
between each order got it yeah and so
what that means yeah I see so you can't
get five all in one go you could you get
two in the go no just one no just the
one one but you can go 500 a day if you
really want to so now part of my routine
is well there's like loads of preps
nearby instead of making a coffee at
home I'll just walk to the nearest prep
I get some fresh air I go to prep and
usually while I'm there ask the team hey
anyone anything I end up buying a bit
more maybe I'll get a box of fruit and
now I I do not go to any coffee shop
other than prep purely because they've
got the Amazon Prime model exactly
I've always wondered why no Hotel chain
has done it where I live in Seven Oaks
or just outside
um and uh basically a taxi home from
London the seven eggs it's about 110 it
used to be famously seven pounds an oak
to Seven Oaks that's one of the black
cab drivers would always quote but it's
now more like 120 yeah
maybe a bit more actually and I'm an
Uber would be a bit less
um but um
uh the interesting thing to me was why
isn't there a deal where I can pay like
Marriott or Intercontinental Hotel Group
and I go look here's the deal I pay you
100 a year okay after 10 p.m I I've
missed my train okay I can check into
any hotel where you have a vacancy and
pay 50 to the thing okay
now you know
um uh interestingly
um I was talking to someone who worked
front of front desk at one of the most
expensive hotels in London who said fun
enough we always used to give the
upgrades to the business Travelers
because two things they only stayed for
one night so you're only giving away the
upgrade for that night but also they
didn't hang around all day demanding
ancillary Bachelor services so they're
actually comparatively cheap to serve
you see now that Arrangement would seem
to me obviously sensible because you
know what's the worst that was gonna
happen well okay you've got the I
suppose you've got the okay you have to
change the bedding and stuff but that's
probably 20 quid 30 quid room turnover
cost at the max okay now that would
strike me as an obvious kind of
symbiotic relationship between hotel
chains and people who live in you know
Tunbridge Wells you know people who live
and particularly you know if people are
moving out to if you think about it with
flexible working if people are moving
out to York well there's no way you can
get a taxi home to York that would be a
pretty damn good deal wouldn't it okay
you've got your you know your crash pad
and yet nobody's done it Costco's done
it Amazon's done it ocado's done it okay
it seems weird to me that you know too
few people have done it why don't you
I'm now actually Tesco is now doing it
with clubcard I think aren't they where
you pay him an extra but you get either
discounts or perks on top yeah
yeah like the waitress card I mean the
only reason I got that was because you
get like 30 off the fresh produce so
fresh I got it thingy and
immediately pays for itself of course of
course I like that train rail card or
anything like that but again it's back
to that psychology of you know friends
and family that I mentioned at the very
beginning of the talk as well you can
make the same discount seem very very
different even if it's identical
economically you can make it very very
different emotionally and that's that's
all that's all I'm saying really is that
the the economics
uh the economic well-being does not
translate into emotional well-being very
well especially if we insist on using
um numerical metrics okay in order to
construct some model okay okay the what
you gain is not a visual kind of
certainty and what you lose is the fact
that in many cases the model barely has
any resemblance to what's really going
on in real life nice right I think
that's a fantastic place to end this
thank you so much pleasure uh where can
people learn more about you uh we'll
obviously put next time Rory Sutherland
uh or one word
um uh uh the books are um now I can
actually say a thank you to Amazon
because although the books sold about
seventy thousand uh wh Smith's have
never stocked it even as a penguin
paperback and so loads of people go who
did the Amazon are killing the bookshops
well yes but equally bookshops weren't
doing any favors to anybody other than
the most mainstream authors so you know
I'm always very very keen by the way
in taking an opposite side of what you
might call the middle class default
position because middle class people are
basically sheep okay it's you know in
other words they're so status conscious
that actually uh they say things for
what they imply not for not for actual
validity okay and one of the things I
often do is defend chains so I'll launch
into a passionate defense of things like
holiday and express Premier Inn and
Travel Lodge let me explain why okay
those things did a fantastic favor to
the UK Hotel industry by setting a floor
okay they're basically pretty good or
better if you want to open a hotel
you've got to be at least that good or
you go out of business therefore I can
confidently book a hotel whether it's a
Travelodge or a non-travel lodge and no
it's going to be at least about as good
as a travel launch okay now in the age
before you had chains like that the same
goes for coffee okay every time you
bought a coffee every time you um you
checked into a hotel you're basically
you know it was a massive gamble with a
fairly High chance that it was absolute
shite
and so it's worth noting okay that
actually there's a value huge value not
just to raising the ceiling there's a
huge value to raising the floor
love it
there was a great guy who was an
independent coffee shop owner who said
I'm not going to diss Starbucks he said
it was those guys who made it possible
for me to charge three pounds for a
coffee in the first place you know he
said if it weren't for Starbucks I
wouldn't have a bigger business I
wouldn't have a business at all yeah
Fair way of looking at it absolutely
right right thank you so much absolute
pleasure all right so that's it for this
week's episode of Deep dive thank you so
much for watching or listening all the
links and resources that we mentioned in
the podcast are going to be linked down
in the video description or in the show
notes depending on where you're watching
or listening to this if you're listening
to this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the iTunes
Store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full HD or 4k on
YouTube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching uh do hit the
Subscribe button if you aren't already
and I'll see you next time bye